vraiment impossible d'oublier cet
incendie majeur il y a cinq ans incendie
qui avait ravagé la résidence du havre
pour personnes âgées à l'île verte
c'était dans la nuit du 23 au 24 janvier
trente deux personnes âgées avaient péri
en 2015 le gouvernement libéral avait
obligé les résidences à se munir de
gicleurs d'ici décembre 2020 citer aussi
les recommandations du coroner qui avait
enquêté sur le drame
qu'en est-il cinq ans plus tard alors
que se tient ce matin une cérémonie
commémorative et il veut desjardins
président du regroupement québécois des
résidences pour aînés est avec moi ce
matin monsieur desjardins bonjour bon
matin tout d'abord vous devez
certainement avoir une pensée pour les
familles des victimes aujourd'hui
absolument vous savez cinq ans après
c'est toujours aussi bouleversant c'est
un événement qu'on n'arrête jamais
souhaité à chaque année on y pense un
dans le domaine des résidences pour
aînés vous savez ici c'était c'est un
drame qui nous ou qui vont nous suivre
toute notre vie et chaque fois qu'on
voit des évacuations également de
résidences pour personnes âgées
comme cette nuit en raison de présence
de monoxyde de carbone mais on y pense à
la difficulté d'évacuer des personnes
comme ça souvent à mobilité réduite dans
des résidences monsieur desjardins ce
qui avait été déterminé c'est que les
raisons se devait se munir de gicleurs
il ya quelques mois on dit que la moitié
des résidences en avait ce que vous avez
un état de situation aujourd'hui au
québec mais écoutez on parle d'environ
1800 résidences pour aînés au québec qui
a un reste peut-être un peu plus de 6
heures à gicler le règlement du jeu pour
2020 il reste deux à ça va être un as en
fait ça va être extrêmement difficile de
rencontrer l'objectif puisqu'il y en
reste comme je disais encore beaucoup à
gicler qu'est ce qui rend la chose aussi
difficiles les conditions financières
des résidences les conditions
financières j'avais que le gouvernement
à deux reprises le même fourni une aide
gouvernementale
on parle d'environ 130 millions ou
global mais c'est l'accès à cette
subvention là qui est absolument
extrêmement difficile il faut que les
résidences contractent un prêt auprès
d'une institution financière d'abord on
pourrait aller chercher à la fin des
travaux le remboursement mais sont pas
en mesure d'aller chercher un prêt
auprès des institutions financières dont
qui n'ont pas finalement la subvention
est ce que c'est une situation que vous
avez exposé à la nouvelle ministre
marguerite blais
absolument j'ai dit à la ministre même
si vous ajoutez 500 millions c'est pas
notre problème
le problème c'est l'accès à la
subvention il faut changer les modalités
permettent aux petites résidences
d'aller chercher aussi très coûteux faut
permettre aux petites résidences d'avoir
un accès plus rapide à la subvention
parce que les gens veulent exécuter des
travaux le sepa sepa sepa là qu'est le
problème le problème c'est vraiment
l'accès à l'argent pour moi exécuter ces
travaux là et le résultat vraiment on
voit de ses résidences qui ferme depuis
des années le chef frappe
je voyais ça monsieur desjardins depuis
trois ans il ya près de 400 résidences
privées pour aînés qui ont fermé leurs
portes
en fait c'est près de 450 résident
majoritairement chez les petites
résidences en milieu rural des jeux il y
avait il ya de la construction il ya de
nouvelles résidences de plus grande
résidence en milieu urbain du fait que
au nom d'unité de l'occasion le on
augmente on a près de dix mille unités
de plus depuis cinq ans mais il reste
qu'il ya 440 résidence qui ont fermé
leurs portes depuis le 1er janvier 2014
difficultés financières difficultés à
recruter également du personnel et
plusieurs enjeux qui touchent les
petites résidences j'avais dit c'est la
difficulté d'arriver la capacité des
aînés parfois n'est pas au rendez vous
on peut pas augmenter les loyers et donc
on peut pas rencontrer les dépenses qui
ne cesse d'augmenter
c'est pas seulement que la
réglementation c'est également la main
d'oeuvre les salaires embête
l'électricité bref les dépenses vont en
augmentant
et les revenus ne sont pas au rendez
vous oui particulièrement est difficile
et monsieur desjardins je rappelle en
terminant qu'il ya cette cérémonie
commémorative en hommage aux victimes de
la résidence du havre de l'isle-verte
cinq ans plus tard vraiment une tragédie
qui avait fait 32 victimes nos équipes
seront sur place monsieur desjardins
merci bien merci à vous avoir en vain